we're back with Lindsay Lohan big day
around here I have to tell you I watched
falling for Christmas last night we did
it is so cute and I it was like such a
family movie I loved it I felt like
everybody could watch it it's the movie
we need right now why a holiday movie
holiday movies are great I mean I've
never been able to be in one and I felt
so lucky to have a script that had a
nice message of just you know the simple
things in life are the most important
and and it just it made me laugh made me
cry it was all the things that I feel
like I loved so I feel like I hope other
people would feel that way too and it's
just it's just a really heartwarming
script
I noticed you're an executive producer
on this movie yes so this was like this
has Lindsay stamp all over it yeah I got
to really be a part of things in a
different way which felt really good
even the editing and the music and I got
to put my sister's song in the movie and
then she did another song and then I got
to put her in the movie so it just it
felt really special to me it was really
nice hey all what was it like being back
on set because how long had it been for
you almost well a long time I mean years
and years it's been yeah and why the
break
I've been going so fast doing movies for
such a long time in my life that I
wanted to really miss it again and so I
was like I'm gonna wait until I and also
I find the right script and I haven't
seen a lot of rom-coms recently that
that I loved and I was like if I I want
to come back now during covet I was
seeing all the movies come out and stuff
and I was like I really miss acting now
what did you miss I just missed being on
set the experiences I make with people
um bringing people joy in their homes
you know doing a great movie and seeing
it come to life just all the little
Parts about it yeah but I love that you
took a second to sort of like pause time
out I want to Define who I am I felt
like maybe that was like your grow up
time to go and sort of take a break yeah
and focus on you and look what happened
you found love you found marriage I know
you made this um Holiday Movie that that
families can watch and it got me
thinking
families right people ask me all the
time Ross when you guys going to have a
kid it's annoying right well because you
don't know I mean right like well that
leads me to my question Lindsay I was
waiting for that one are people asking
all the time like congratulations on the
wedding when also all my friends have
have kids yes the moms are really
pushing for it
so the more grandkids the merrier
so Lindsay yeah
I'll just keep talking around it yeah
okay
okay are you are you you're feeling this
that's definitely something yes of
course I want kids in the future you'd
be such a great mom thank you oh we're
going there thank you you can go
wherever you are I don't want to
pressure you but I just I don't know I
think the best parents are the parents
who have like lived life and know a
thing or two yeah and can tell their
kids a thing or two about a thing or two
yeah yeah maybe down the line yeah don't
like I've seen my niece all the time and
I just it's hard to not want kids when
I'm with her I get it she's just the
cutest thing ever oh I hope you're a mom
with that I just I wish that for you I
think that'd be so cute
um and are you able to take this moment
in because I started the interview
talking to you about like this Johanna
sons that we needed you that we missed
you yeah it's a great thing didn't come
up with it we saw it online but I'm
honored but you feel it do you feel the
love I do I feel the love I feel really
grateful and really blessed right now
that was good I'm so glad you feel it
because we're like we're giving it to
you
um you know before we we before we go to
commercial I was zooming with Drew
before this interview you know she's
homesick and she's like I said she sends
her love and she gave me a list of
questions she had to ask you it's our
final five are you ready for some rapid
fire questions
final time let's do it
okay first up from Drew what is the last
thing you ate I had an egg omelet this
morning ooh anything in it ham and
cheese cute okay protein heavy all right
what is the latest song you have on
repeat
um Without You by Aliana Lohan yes you
do oh Ally Lohan who it's gonna be
coming out here right after the breaks
thank you for that do you have any
reoccurring dreams
I I don't really know what's the best
advice that you've ever heard
um family is the most important thing
make time for family I love that your
sister's here your mom's here too right
yeah so you you walk the talk right and
finally if you could have dinner with
one person in history who would it be
besides Ross Matthews
um
like Mother Teresa
that's a good one I have a lot of
questions yeah I thought what would you
ask her what would you I don't know yeah
that's a good choice yeah yeah it would
be her
foreign
[Music]